hey everyone this is GQ recommends and
today we are going to talk about
sunglasses
[Music]
So today we're going to break down in
detail four essential categories of
sunglasses that you should be familiar
with not only this season but every
season going forward
time classic
these are the sunglasses that just work
you think about the Wayfarer the
clubmaster a pair of personals a lot of
these sunglasses have been around for a
long time they look good and they have a
lot of history to them these are the
sunglasses that you can grab and always
feel comforted in that you're going to
look cool they're tried and shoot
Classics for a reason yeah definitely
and in particular the one we're looking
at here the Ray-Ban clubmaster which is
perhaps the most legendary of them all
for good reason they're a super
legendary shape that really took off in
the 50s and 60s as regular eyeglasses
they kind of have this ivy league look
to them which is super cool without
being overly Point Dexter towards the
latter half of that decade they also
became popular sunglasses guys like
Malcolm X very famously wore them and
they've kind of stood the test of time
because they are in almost universally
flattering silhouette no matter which
way your style skews they come in a
bunch of different colors they're fairly
reasonably placed for the quality you're
getting and they're stamped with Ray-Ban
sign of quality which is pretty hard to
beat on the other end of the spectrum
you have a brand like personal in some
ways ray-ban's Italian counterpart you
want us walk us through the most
legendary silhouette from Purcell's deep
repertoire yeah for sure
her soul is another really iconic brand
you might have seen this on guys like
Steve McQueen this is sort of an aviator
style which comes in a lot of different
materials and slightly different shapes
but this style was really born for
military Pilots to really cover more of
the face and block out more sun a lot of
race car drivers actually thought this
silhouette really worked well driving
their fast cars do I look fast you look
super fast man I drive a Ford Focus what
can you tell us about this last pair
well I'm glad you asked Gerald because
these are one of my personal favorites
this is a Wayfarer style pair of
sunglasses from the French eyewear
experts at Jack marimaj they're handmade
in Japan out of some of the finest
quality materials on the planet you know
that they're going to last you for years
provided you can keep your hands on them
and won't lose them in the back of a
taxi there are some sunglasses that are
made from straight up just plastic like
the same kind you would get from a water
water bottle or something these are not
fat they feel weighty they feel dense
they don't feel brittle like they're
just going to snap on you but then you
know you get into sunglasses that are
like wire frame sunglasses that are
really thin and lightweight that doesn't
necessarily mean it's a poor quality but
get a pair of sunglasses and it feels
pretty weighty it's probably not a bad
sign but along with the higher quality
materials you also get a lot of details
that you probably won't see on cheaper
alternatives so there's this nice gold
trim here the color in particular is
also like this Rich shade of almost
mocha brown that's hard to come by in
this particular tint
colors
the Technicolor tents the all-time
classics are always a safe bet we really
like those Silhouettes but if you're
looking for sunglasses with a little bit
more personality you could also play
around with not only shape size and
silhouette but color they're not for the
faint of heart but if you can get past
the bright colors they're actually
pretty easy to pull off this first pair
is from a brand called Sun buddies
pretty affordable and like the quality
is really great for the price too not so
crazy as far as the silhouette goes but
what does stand out is this I don't know
kind of like magenta-ish color they look
great thanks this color is not something
you usually you see every day it's not
the usual tortoise shell it's not boring
gray it UPS the ante considerably yeah
for sure
these are the blue ECMO sunglasses from
retro Super Future which is a really
cool brand that we like a lot that also
makes fairly affordable sunglasses
they've got a Sleek outline they're kind
of squared off at the top and a little
bit rounded at the bottom they work well
on most face shapes and like we were
saying before they've got this mid auth
energy that's really hot right now I
could easily see fever wearing these I
like it because it is a little bit
curved at the bottom which I think
softens the angularity of the frames but
yes this smaller frame with the very
flat top is something we're seeing a lot
of lately I personally love another
brand called Aquila these are some of my
own sunglasses this brand makes a lot of
different frames really fashion forward
they also do have some Classics of
course as any good sunglass brands
should most of their sunglasses are
around 120 bucks really good quality and
you can find a bunch of them in you know
the full spectrum lens tints and frame
colors these look sick with your current
outfit yeah I guess I didn't really plan
that out actually
what would you normally wear these with
I would generally keep everything else
pretty chill that being said you liked
how this looks matching my shirt you do
that too well I think it's because the
elements of your outfit are already
pretty paired down like it's essentially
just a white tee and like neutral color
Cargoes but the flannel and sunglasses
level it up these are set thanks so if
you think this category is a little too
wild just stop the video now exit find
something else because we're gonna get
even crazier in just a second
the total swerves
these are the wild style sunglasses
they've been around in one form or
another for decades you can see them on
people like Brad Pitt Pharrell they pack
a lot of style per square inch into a
very small silhouette and that's kind of
cool there's not really a category for
this on you know whatever retail site
you're looking at so these are just wild
sunglasses it's not a specific shape
it's not a specific color or brand or
whatever if your Styles tends to skew
more Pare down and you don't really like
to go big with the rest of your outfit
this is a perfect way to flex your taste
and show up everyone else wherever you
happen to be this first pair is from a
brand called brain dead which all around
makes really dope stuff this hits on a
lot of different points the lenses are
super reflective and like crazy almost
mirror-like the frames are like this
slime green sort of take on turtle shell
that bit of hardware on the lenses is
super cool I think actually
I think Kim Kardashian wore a pair of
these this style is called the mutant
which I mean if there's any way to
really swerve in this category it's with
something like this it's a deceptively
approachable frame mostly because the
silhouette itself is pretty universally
flattering so if you can look past or in
fact Embrace everything else going on
it's going to look good on your face you
want to tell us about this next pair so
these are actually from Cutler and gross
which I think you and I both really like
it's one of the Premier names in higher
end sunglasses they don't come cheap
they're almost 500 bucks but again they
come with a pedigree that is pretty hard
to beat in the sunglasses space they're
super high quality they feel really
Hefty in your hand but not so Hefty that
they'll weigh down your face when you're
wearing them what I really dig about
these is that they are heavily doused
with like retro Peak 70s energy so you
see a lot of guys wearing these on the
red carpet people like Anderson pack and
Bruno Mars I feel like these types of
sunglasses are the sort of Shades you
want to throw on when you're going to
like a destination wedding with a pretty
lack dress code where you have free
reign to add a little personality to
your fit I don't know if I would wear
them to a more conventional black tie
wedding or a funeral
yeah probably not I wouldn't I wouldn't
do that either I don't think stunting on
the bereaved is necessarily in good
taste
take it away my man from a Japanese
brand called matsuda known for really
intricate sunglasses they're not all
necessarily as wild as this but I mean
straight from the jump jeez these are
based off of vintage welding sunglasses
all metal it's like very steampunk I
actually have another pair of matsudas
that are not at all like this they have
a really wide range of styles and
Silhouettes if the pair that you like
flies against the conventional wisdom
whatever the keyboard Warriors are
telling you looks best on your face
shape so be it you should commit
wholeheartedly and whatever makes you
feel the most confident is the pair you
should rock with yeah agreed so Gerald
the mitsuda pair that you were just
talking about I think these are like
1500 bucks right which is an objectively
absurd amount of money to spend on
sunglasses I don't think either you or I
would Fork over that money so easily
without a second thought what's great
about this category is that it ranges so
wide and you can find plenty of
sunglasses that are really cool and
really swervy at lower price points we
really like a brand called crap eyewear
as funny as the name is they make some
really cool sunglasses you know just
around 100 bucks or even less
the Sporting Life these sunglasses come
from a place of pure function a lot of
them are built for the specific type of
activity you'll be wearing them in shag
and fly balls running into the end zone
or just running into your homies on the
way to pick up some breakfast sandwiches
bang Sound by free I mean these days
we're seeing a lot of these sunglasses
not on any type of sports field
whatsoever they've evolved from Beyond
their purely performance routes evolved
yeah or have been forcibly yanked yeah
let's say that athletic brands Nike
Adidas Oakley are some of the most
popular names but there are plenty of
fashion brands that are getting into
these types of sunglasses I've yet to
see a team sponsored by like a high
fashion house but that would be pretty
cool I like Balenciaga X MLB or Prada
and the NBA that would be safe
yeah to your point Gerald there's also
like a ton of non-athletes who swear by
these Styles like Justin Bieber has been
wearing the Balenciaga version of this
type of sunglass pretty religiously on
tour and Bad Bunny routinely Sports them
on the red carpets but I think it's that
element of sport influence design that
makes them really cool and kind of adds
a little bit of edge or like an
unexpected flavor so the first pair that
I'm looking at here are from Nike these
are a pretty classic example of the
silhouette cantilevered shape super
glossy finish definitely a polarized
lens and a hint of neon on either side
of the temple there so the second pair
we're going to take a look at are from
Westward leaning how do they make you
feel they look pretty sick I feel pretty
sick if you're say like running at night
they've got the yellow tint and it
actually brightens things up so
depending on the color of the lenses
they'll give you you know better Acuity
in some areas and not others so it
really depends on the activity so do you
think these types of sunglasses have to
be worn with running gear or gear that's
specifically made for athletic
performance I don't think you have to
I've seen plenty of people look really
cool in a sort of like Y2K kind of vibe
I think you would probably agree Gerald
that no discussion of sportier Shades
would be complete without mention of
Oakley which is sort of the OG when it
comes to the genre they've been making
styles that like we said evolved from
their athletic pedigree to be a staple
on the street as well the classic
silhouette is the radar EV path which is
a little over 240 bucks sounds like a
lot but you get a ton of functionality
and performance with one pair of Shades
if you don't want to buy them new I
scoop this pair second hand basic
silhouette hasn't changed much over the
years but they make me feel like a
multi-million dollar athlete every time
I wear them and I don't even have an
endorsement deal not yet at least
there's no denying how functional these
are and if there's anything that we've
learned from a lot of wardrobe Classics
that we continue to wear a day that's
kind of where icons come from is
functionality so I wouldn't be surprised
if these are still here decades from now
so Gerald you're saying that I could
probably pull off a pair of these you
yeah sure yeah okay so if I can pull
them off you can definitely pull them
off
[Music]
so which one of these guys was your
favorite
it's probably these guys right here I
think they're the most fun but maybe not
one I'd wear every day was yours
honestly I feel like my taste is a
little more conventional I dug these a
lot and I feel like I would get a lot of
wear out of them
thanks so much for watching and if you
like what you saw you can check out all
the links right below